So that's a little
background out of the way.
Now you can probably see where
I'm heading with all this.
Someone who can't see the screen,
can't access the visual
information in the interface.
And someone who is using voice control
relies on the voice control software
being able to interact
with the web page.
So we need to make sure that
information is expressed in a way which
is flexible enough to be accessed
programatically by assistive technology.
Which can then create an alternative
user interface to suit its users needs.
We refer to this as expressing
the semantics of an element.
The Web AIM checklist explicitly calls
this outing guideline 4.1, saying name,
role, value, markup is used in a way
that facilitates accessibility.
Okay, that's kind of terse.
The Web Content Accessibility Guidelines
go into a bit more detail.
For all user interface
components the name and
role can be programmatically determined.
States, properties and
values that can be set by the user
can be programmatically set.
So what are name role and value?
And how can we make sure that they can
be programmatically determined and set?
To answer that, we're going to start off
by trying things out from the point of
view of someone using
assistive technology.
Just before we jump into that I want
to quickly mention that in this course
we will be working mostly
with screen readers.
But a lot of the work we do
to support screen readers
also benefits users who use
other assistive technologies.
Things like voice control and
switch control use the same
programmatically expressed semantics.
In the introduction we had a first
look at using a screen reader.
Now were going to try using
one without any access to
the web pages visible interface